what I want to talk about really is the
art of being bold because without that
you can't get anything in life you can't
do anything if you're not willing to put
yourself out there and that takes
boldness boldness is a skill and you
don't have to be bore and bold to be
bold in your life you have to harness
and learn how to be bold like you would
any other skill you want to master like
karate or Spanish or whatever it is
mediocrity is a strength remember the
people that you are looking up to are
truly mediocre but have a lot of grit
that's what it is do not count yourself
out before putting yourself in the game
first that's when it comes down to you
have to believe that why not you the
road map to self-belief is a myth it's a
farce it's not like you first do step
one and do step two and then by step
five you're gonna have self-belief
because life doesn't work that way would
you say oh wow nobody's flipped it on me
I was all ready to end the show and cut
believe Nation we have a very special
guest the one and only Jennifer Cohen
has a new book out it's right here
bigger better Bolder she's got a copy
she's holding it up there too and I'm
hoping she's gonna help me be bolder in
this session and then I've also got some
questions that I want to ask her from
the book but as I'm going through what
you created I don't think I'm bold
enough now when I when I looked at yeah
well this is a natural reaction people
like what you're doing so many big
things you're trying to change the world
and all these things and as I look at
the 16 principles of boldness that
you're outlining the book I can identify
with with a significant amount of them
but I also I feel like I'm not a big
risk taker
I maybe maybe risk taking and boldness
are not the same thing but if I come to
you and say okay Jennifer
I don't feel bold enough
how would you coach me or what questions
would you ask because this is a legit
thing for me really that's amazing that
you're you're right because looking at
you from the outside you would think
that you've been pretty bold and you've
been you take on so many projects which
is interesting because a lot of times
you could be bold in some areas of your
life and not bold in other areas it's
not like a it's not one of these things
that's overarching that like if you're
bold you're bold every and everywhere
you could be very bold in your personal
life with relationships and then with
your career have self-doubt and then
hold yourself back so the first thing I
want to tell people is that boldness is
a skill and you don't have to be born
bold to be bold in your life you have to
harness and learn how to be bold like
you would any other skill you want to
master like karate or Spanish or
whatever it is so that's the first thing
so people who are listening to this
don't think if you weren't born that way
that it's like you're doomed because
it's not true the second part I want to
say is the way that we get better at
everything including being bold right is
to actually practice and we do that by
doing we doing by doing something
consistently all the time so I would say
to you Evan if you don't feel your bold
you can get better at being bold by
doing little bold moves daily to work
that bold muscle and over time that bold
muscle will get bigger and bigger and
stronger and stronger and like if you
stop doing it it will atrophy and it
will get smaller a lot of times the big
thing is people are fearful and they are
scared that they aren't smart enough
talented enough pretty enough
so then they don't even pursue
so I would say to that you know what all
those things are irrelevant because that
those things aren't the things that take
you on the path to being successful
anyway you and I both know that right
it's the people who actually move and
act I would say someone you have to
learn to be bolder by let's say doing
these small things it could be as small
as going to a restaurant and asking for
salad dressing on the side it could be
something of hey you know what my I've
been paying 200 a month on my cell
service for five years what if I called
my self-service provider maybe there's a
better plan out there and once you start
asking and being more audacious it
becomes much more natural in other areas
if you don't feel comfortable asking for
small things in your life you're never
going to be more comfortable asking for
the big things in life so you start by
doing these small little moves that get
you more comfortable so you can ask and
be more both later on how's that for an
answer I like Instagram it's great I
love it we're diving in I know you're
talking the book about the two kinds of
you know boldness one being around
social where like you're afraid to ask
people and talk to people there's this
exhibit at Walt Disney World I don't
know if you've seen it Indiana Jones
spectacular which is like a 40-minute
live show where he's you know I totally
remember that okay so I always skip that
so when we go family trips I skip it
I've seen it like a million times okay
and I skip it because right down the
street in Walt Disney World there's this
Legend of Walt Disney exhibit where you
kind of walk through the history of Walt
Disney and why you started Walt Disney
World and where all the dreams came from
and it's super boring for most people
which is why like the kids go to go
watch Indiana Jones and I get my 40
minutes to kind of peruse and watch Walt
Disney and here's a guy who like went
almost went bankrupt twice like betting
it all on his giant projects when nobody
believed in him and made magic happen
and yeah
I think by the way not to interrupt you
but he actually went bankrupt multiple
times I think it was more like 10 times
crazy amounts of times yeah but maybe
it's just a definition of boldness
because I look at that and say I that is
crazy like I would never risk that much
but I think I could risk a little more
and my biggest my biggest strength is
probably just consistently getting up
every day and doing the work for 14
years of YouTube videos but uh I don't
think that I'm bold enough you know when
I look at that I want to be bolder I
feel insignificant compared to Walt
Disney so not as a negative way like I
suck but as a like how do I catch some
of this magic to have me be more bold so
when I saw this like okay I'm gonna ask
Jennifer she she's gonna give me an
answer I'm gonna tell you I think that's
interesting I do this speaking thing
um what am I speaking speeches I
actually use Walt Disney as an example
right and I talk about all these people
who have failed like just multiple
multiple times like the Dyson guy you
know the Kentucky Fried Chicken Colonel
Sanders and what made them different
than anybody else is that they practice
resilience and they practice failure and
it's they didn't look at failure as
failure but they looked at it as an
attempt and that's how I look at it I
look at failure as one attempt my second
failure second attempt third attempt and
if we reframe what failure is to us in
our brains it allows us to
basically go through the world
differently and the funny thing is
people who the people who've actually
been the most successful because they
failed the most right and you know I
feel like a lot of times well I put
together this thing it's called the 10
Target and the 10 Target
is this thing where I say to people
pick one thing that you really want pick
one goal
um it could be anything and you have to
make 10 attempts at getting to that goal
and the truth of the matter is Evan most
of the time truthfully you may not get
to that goal but two things will happen
either you will get the goal you will
get to that thing but while you're on
that path it teaches you failure most
people don't even make one attempt
almost nobody makes two attempts so if
you're somebody who's going to be making
10 attempts or that's the goal you're
threat you want but it also teaches you
that it teaches you to get comfortable
with that failure it builds that
resilience because the more you do
something you become desensitized to
what what's happening so if you fail and
you do it over and over and over again
that feeling of failure becomes a new
you become immune to that feeling right
because you've been doing it you're more
comfortable with it and the other thing
is if even if you don't get to that goal
another opportunity will present itself
that you never even knew existed by
going down that path because the reality
is something in motion stays in motion
something stagnant stays stagnant so if
you can teach people and to explain to
people that just by you acting by you
doing that in itself will give you
opportunities and open up doors you
otherwise would never have expected
because you're actually in the you're in
the mix right you're not going to be in
the mix by sitting at your on your couch
and just hoping and thinking and maybe
enough like that analysis paralysis gets
you nowhere or that hope and if you can
reframe all of these things and think
about the factors you know what
why not me you know like I would rather
be rejected than have the idea of regret
later on to me the idea of like what ifs
if I did that what would be to me that's
guttural and it will last forever but
rejection what is it like it may hurt
and sting for like a minute a day two
days but you eventually get over it but
the idea of not even attempting not even
putting yourself in a place of of maybe
what if that small chance actually
worked out for yourself to me that will
let that lasts a lifetime
the worst feeling is not at
self-actualizing and not using your
potential in my opinion
how do you help people through even
identifying the thing that they're
afraid of because when they're thinking
of these ideas they'll they'll come up
with very logical practical reasons why
they can't do something but that's not
really the answer there's something
underneath some fear some insecurity so
how do you help people kind of cut
through their own BS to figure out the
real reason why they're afraid to take
action
but you're right because I think that's
exactly absolutely true I think we all
kind of use all these like silly little
reasons and excuses for not doing
something but I I believe that we all
really know deep down with that core
what that root cause is right so I think
a big piece of this is self-awareness I
think you can't help somebody if they
don't want to help themselves that's
with anything in life in Everett area to
be bold to lose weight whatever the
reason is so someone has to really have
a come to Jesus with themselves and say
what is it about myself that I don't
think I can win a lot of the times
people don't believe in themselves
because they don't think they're smart
enough typically right or they don't
think depending on what it is that they
don't they don't have uh the the
pedigree for it they don't have the
connections for it but at the end of the
day people don't think they're good
enough that's why they look at everybody
else and they compare themselves to
everybody else and the problem is now
with social media and everything else
everything becomes a compare game you
know like everyone feels even more down
about themselves more depressed more um
unworthy because they look at other
people on Instagram and think well they
have a great life you know you know I
wish I could be that way but I don't
have this I think a big piece of a lot
of this is stop comparing yourself to
everybody else that's the number one
that's the number one thing and
realizing that Instagram and reality are
very very different and the people that
you're looking at aren't even the people
you're really looking at and you have to
think to yourself if they can do it why
can't I why not me you're going to think
well if if that Yahoo can do it why
can't I because the truth is most the
people who are crushing it are barely
mediocre that's the reality that people
don't realize and you and I both know
this a lot of the people that you and I
know we look at like I think to myself
how the hell that person do it like I
they're they're not they're they're no
great shakes they're they're not any
they're nothing phenomenal but they had
what they had that most people don't
have is they had tenacity and they had
the audacity to think that they can and
if you have the audacity to think that
you can you will that is the bottom line
it's not because that that person is any
better than the person over here it's
because that one person had that self
belief in themselves inflated or not
right that's what it comes down to you
have to believe that you why not you I
love the line that that the people
you're looking at aren't the people that
you're looking at it's great it's a
great it's great it's true no I agree
it's great I've never kind of heard it
put that way so it's great I mean you
talk about believe that's
uh
I Look to these people and like and I'm
not going to name any needs I'm like how
in God's name does that person get to
there it's it's only they're not they're
not that smart they're not that they're
not that you know Wise they're not that
profound they're not that anything
talented but it's because a they put in
the time and work because they believe
in themselves and those people truly are
like when you meet them in person you're
like they're not at all what you think
they're gonna be so narrowing in on
believe I think it's the biggest problem
in the world that people don't believe
in themselves how do we how do we solve
that problem how do we solve the problem
of improving our self-belief you just
start doing it you know I find that
there's there really is the road map to
self-belief is a myth it's a farce it's
not like you first do step one then do
step two and then by step five you're
gonna have self-belief because life
doesn't work work that way the only real
way to get self-belief is to actually do
these little things that you make a
commitment you two and actually follow
through and that will build your
confidence and self-belief so what I
would say is
self-belief equals self-confidence how
do you do that if I say Jennifer or Evan
you know I am going to do X tomorrow
okay whatever that is okay I'm gonna
work out 20 minutes tomorrow at seven
o'clock seven a.m okay and then I
actually follow through with that
commitment and do that seven o'clock
workout for 20 minutes you know what I
just like put a tick in the
self-confidence box because I made a
commitment I followed through and I did
it yay me and I do it over and over and
over again that builds your
self-confidence if I said to myself or
yourself you know tomorrow I'm going to
work out I'm gonna 7 A.M I'm gonna do my
20 minutes
and guess what I hit the snooze button I
didn't do it you know what I let myself
down I didn't like follow through to
what I said I would do I let myself down
that is a a check in the you know low
self-esteem theme because that will that
that breathes lower low self the stadium
when you can't even follow through with
the commitments that you made to
yourself that brings yourself belief
system lower so the best way to really
increase your your self-belief your
self-confidence is when you make make
these small little commitments to
yourself
follow through with them and that
feeling of accomplishment and and the
fact that you actually did that helps
overall build that self-confidence and
change that neuroplasticity in your
brain other than that there really is no
such thing there is no road map
everything is internal there's nothing
external that can really build that out
for you any kind of validation external
validation is is trite and completely
unnecessary because it only lasts for a
finite period of time if you said to me
Evan Jennifer you're so amazing you're
so smart you're so this you're so that
you will that make me feel great for 10
15 minutes yeah and then I'll move on
and I'll something else will happen and
I'll get right back to that place those
things are very
they they're very fleeting we've got to
figure out ways in ourselves to build
our own self-confidence internally or
else it doesn't last and so the only way
to do that truly is to actually fulfill
the commitments that you make to
yourself that's really the only way
Dan Sullivan has a great question which
she asked people uh which is who do you
want to be a hero to
and I'm I'm curious for you when this
book and the mission that you're on who
do you want to be a hero to
I want to be a hero to my kids
to myself
um to me that's you know to people in my
family who I love to me that's the only
really that's that's what I want to do I
want to be a good a role model and a
good example for my little daughter
who's seven years old and my son who's
10. I want them
to see somebody
who uh chases what they want and not
just accepts what they get and
acquiesces to the good enough I think
that's that's really the message here is
that as a being a people we tend to just
acquiesce to what's in front of us we
take what's good enough and just live
our lives that way versus being
deliberate and curating the life that we
want we just kind of accept the life
that we get and stay on that path and so
if I can do anything I was I can be a
hero a role model it would be to the
people like my kids to be like you know
what my mom she she didn't do that she
went after it she worked really hard she
she carved her own paths between her own
she paved her own way and because of
that I'm gonna do the same and to me
that's what it's about you know if
that's and and for myself too you know I
I don't want to I don't want to look
back that react to the whole rejection
regret situation I don't want to look
back at my life and think God you know
what I could have done that but I was
too lazy or I should have tried that but
I was too scared so what I say to that
is like when you're scared and when you
don't want to do it anyway
because when you do it anyway you'll be
surprised and amazed at what actually
happens how do we raise Bolder kids by
being a good role model by being a good
example by you being bold by the parent
being bold by teaching them that it's
okay to stand up for yourself and ask
for what you want I think that we have
we have a misconception of what what
being bold is I think that people can
Think Bold as being pushy or abrasive or
rude and I think that we have to change
that dialogue and I think the way you
you raise bold confident kids is to be
an example by doing it first because
kids mimic and they learn by by visually
watching what you do not by just what
you say right by what you can you can
talk a lot but who cares if you're not
acting and walking the walk it doesn't
matter that's the first thing second of
all like I said like you you do it by by
Leading by the example because the
reality is I want my kid to be confident
enough to stand up for themselves and
actually pave a path for themselves that
makes them happy and no one's no one
ultimately ultimately is going to have a
rich life that's happy and fulfilling
unless they curated for themselves
I love it I think your your version of
boldness is interesting because you're
thinking way outside the box you've got
16 principles of basically what it means
to be bold and then looking through them
you have things like be curious or
insatially curious about the exact
wording of it like huh okay curiosity I
didn't see that as a bold trait but what
are some of the weird traits or the as
you've kind of got the book out into the
world like oh I didn't realize I was
actually bold by following some of these
habits I think curiosity is like a
sister or a brother to being bold
because
um curiosity I think is essential
in the sense that when you are curious
that's how you that's how you glean a
lot of information right for people and
from things is when you ask questions
when you're interested in things and the
amount of opportunities come from from
that that type of that from curiosity is
is amazing but curiosity also breeds
connection to people uh Community it
builds it builds uh relationships
connections Community like everything
comes from Curiosity and curiosity helps
you then figure out what you want more
and then you could be then you can be
bold by going after it so that's the
first thing but I also think that I've
talked in the book about another
principle is naivety how naivety is a
strength because in my opinion sometimes
the less you know the better right like
the people who know too much tend to
overthink everything and they end up
doing nothing they think about all the
things that can go wrong and they they
put out all the spreadsheets and data
points and analytics and then they end
up like basically in this like analysis
paralysis where they can't even figure
out their way out of a you know paper
bag because they have too much
information versus people who know
nothing because when you know when you
don't know what you don't know and so
when you're naive and just have no
information you just end up going and
you figure it out as you go and in my
life that's basically been me like I've
I've I know nothing about nothing but
what I do have is this skill of life
I've really harnessed my skill of being
bold and I just like go for stuff and on
that path you know not only do you
figure things out but that's how you fit
that's how other things kind of like
appear to you where then you can like
course correct and that's how you
disrupt an industry I think because if
you're just gonna do it the same way
everybody else did it then what's the
point right so I think that having that
naivety like people should they take
anything from this this
um conversation I would say is if you
feel like you don't know enough or
you're not experienced enough or you're
you know you're just too not enough of
something perfect that's when you go I
love it and looking through the 16
principles you see things like oh okay
I'm curious I can be naive this is great
I'm Bolder than I thought I was exactly
I
mediocre mediocre's another one though I
I think we could have talked with the
mediocre a little bit but let me just
like really kind of hammer at home okay
mediocrity is a strength remember the
people that you're looking up to are
truly mediocre but to have much but have
a lot of grit that's what it is you know
like do not count yourself out before
putting yourself in the game first
so what were some of the Bold things you
had to do to to write this book to
promote this book to get it out to the
world like what were the some of the
things that made you shaking your boots
a little bit before creating it or
creating well but the book is full
filled with just a full of just examples
of things in my life that uh were things
that were bold moves that I had to do
and a lot of things that I did didn't
work out for me but how with me going
through the process actually ended up
working out better for me because and
and how it can also be applied to other
people because the truth the matter is
also I should say that every failure is
one dot that connects you to something
else that you don't even know how it
actually works itself out right like
every time I failed in something it
actually worked out to my advantage but
later on I saw that but I didn't see it
in that moment time so people should
remember that but I feel like
with everything and I I try to do this
with everything I do is I like to give
people practical actionable things that
they can do to actually Implement to
change their lives as opposed to
speaking from this like white Ivory
Tower of of like uh
of information because the reality is
people have to go through it I use
myself as an example of things that
worked for me and how it can actually
help other people learn from and I love
how easy the book is to read lots of
headlines lots of tool tips lots of like
standout things so you're not reading
like a novel because if I'm going past
it down
very very breathable very easy to use
what was what was the biggest ask or the
boldest ask
that you had to do for this book
whether it worked out or not listen I
think a few a bunch of things getting a
book
and then promoting the book is a
ball of wax you know and
people don't realize that it's the
iceberg you know it's the it's the it's
the iceberg right people see the tip
they don't see all the stuff that
happens underneath like even this
interview with you the amount of asking
and favors and reaching out and all the
other stuff that happens for when this
book has for me to actually promote this
book is it's exhausting and so this book
actually is a lot how I've had to
promote this book and talk about this
book is me asking people to help me
promote it to help me uh you know get
into their audience their communities uh
all that stuff I mean there's all that
stuff and even the fact of like putting
yourself out there over and over again
for so much rejection is like part of
the is part of the whole process and I
don't want to bore you to death but I
can give you so many details about it
but the reality is I mean anything that
you do requires you to have to put
yourself in a place of rejection and
um and possible rejection which is
basically what I've been going through
this whole time and was it something
that you were still nervous and scared
to do or you've just trained the muscle
so much that okay I'm just I'm just
gonna reach out to people if they reject
me they reject me
no no I mean I'm always nervous I mean
the reality is you never stop getting
nervous I like I said like the reality
is being the whole idea is if it's
boldness is like a muscle it is
something you have to work overtime
constantly right like it's not something
you just do it for like three months and
now now I'm bold the reality is you have
to keep on doing it and work that muscle
over and over again and even then you
know it gets tired you know it is a
break and all these other things right
the thing is I just have learned that I
maybe I'm stronger than I other people
because I've done it for so long but the
truth of the matter is at the same time
it's okay like you could that's boldness
is for Life there have been a lot of
times when I still get myself in a
situation where I'm like oh my God you
know I don't want to do that and I end
up not doing something and I feel even
worse later on because I didn't didn't I
had that regret that I didn't even do it
but people have to realize that it's
something that they have to do all the
time to maintain the that maintain their
skill
behind me I've got uh braces and I broke
my neck in 2019 while I was on tour it
was a three month tour 90 days 23 cities
and two-thirds of the way through I
break my neck and everybody tells me go
home and I said you know what I'm going
to try broke your neck Yeah I broke my
neck in two spots
and I just want I want to at least try
to keep going and we missed one spot
because I had a concussion too so like I
was in the hospital on one day so I
couldn't do that but then all the other
stops I still showed up and did and I
was gonna throw these away because
they're kind of nasty like you're
wearing that for 60 days straight could
take it off for 10 minutes but my friend
said keep it as a as a reminder of your
boldness and when I look at that like
man I don't know if I could do that
again you know like I look back like I
was pretty badass back in 2019 I don't
know if I broke my neck again would I
keep going for another month on tour
hitting eight more cities but it's a
reminder that like that's who is inside
me that I try to tap into and why it's
kind of sitting here on the wall so how
do you I like that that's really I like
that people need those reminders people
everyone should have those things around
them to remind them who they really are
inside because life happens a lot of
times and life can also knock you down
and you can tend to forget you know all
these things that we're capable of
unless we actually put it to action if
we don't and it like like I said it
atrophies and we forget what what that
potential is if we keep it dormant for
too long in talking about looking at
people's Instagram feeds and it being
like the Highlight Reel of that person's
life and not their actual life it just
made me think that hey this is like the
Highlight Reel of my actual life of my
my bold life so how do we create uh the
environment whether it's our physical
environment whether it's like reading
books watching videos podcasts like how
do we create the environment of boldness
because most people watching this they
probably already are the boldest person
in their family the boldest person that
they know it's an entrepreneur audience
they're the ones giving and encouraging
others yet also plain small so how do we
create that environment for us to remind
us to be bold on a regular basis
that what you just you said it in in
your question which is creating the
environment for us to win and how you do
that is I I believe you have to create
routine structures and habits that put
you in a place to win and get you a
plate to be your optimal place of
productivity so for me having a very
strong morning routine where I do my
hard stuff first number one that gives
me that feeling of accomplishment again
it makes me feel like great I did it I
feel accomplished it gives me that
mental uh confidence to kind of keep on
going and pushing through through things
I think putting yourself like I said
building a a group of people called The
Bold of directors I call it the bolded
directors right like having a group of
people who are your support system that
want you to win
and that help you get to where you need
to go I don't believe in life that
anybody in life is self-made I believe
everybody needs other people to help
them get to from point A to point B to
point C you know making sure you're very
conscientious of who you're asking
advice from you know a lot of times
you're asking advice from people who
have never even walked that walk or gone
through that and then you're letting
them dictate what you're going to do so
I feel like being very very deliberate
on who is in that bowl the directors
picking people who are like-minded who
want you to win who help build you up
and who can help Elevate you to the and
and help you in other ways get to that
place I think the boulder directors I
think have healthy habits I think
creating the environment that's how you
create the environment for yourself to
win and I always tell people like I'm
like I love food like you know I see the
the first thing I I dialed in on are
those Doritos I'm like oh my God that's
the first thing I saw I didn't see the
neck brace or anything else behind you
and because why I'm bringing that up is
I know myself I know if I I love to eat
and if I whenever I go to a buffet I end
up eating so much I'm sick I feel gross
I open my pants you know the whole thing
so what do I do I won't allow myself to
go to a buffet because I know what's
going to happen I know what the outcome
is going to be right I'm going to feel
gross I'm going to overeat so then I I
take away that trigger for myself so
what I tell people and what I want to
say to everybody is like know thyself
know what your triggers are what puts
you off path to be the the best version
of yourself and then reverse engineer
that and don't put your yourself in
places that you're gonna lose and put
you in a downward spiral that's what I
say I say like your environment is the
most important thing that you have to
make you be the best winner that you can
possibly be the best bold person that
you can be and the other part is the
people you surround yourself with which
is why I talk about the boulder
directors people are always asking about
the Doritos is like can you not get a
healthier sponsor of your videos why are
like why Doritos like if Doritos knew
why they were here they would not want
to sponsor my videos uh I have a
strategy called Damn the Doritos where
my vice is Doritos like I want to eat
that whole bag that's a that's a pretty
giant bag it is it doesn't look giant
oh wow yeah it's in the background but
like this is a pretty giant bag of
Doritos and wow my mouth is watering
just looking at this right now but
my strategy is hey damn the Doritos
because if you if I if I can't go to an
office party or a cruise ship or
whatever and not just like stuff my face
then I can only win when I'm in like the
perfect I love the environment and I
want to not only win on in the perfect
environment and so it's like when I look
at this like damn to Doritos like I'm
stronger than you Doritos and uh that's
hilarious I'll often film videos because
in the U.S I'm Canadian but you
Americans have oh are you are you
Canadian yeah like you Americans have
like a thousand flavors of Doritos and
the Oreos are even more ridiculous all
the Oreo flavors and so I'll go to when
I'm in the states I'll take videos and
like yell at the Oreos and the Doritos
I'm stronger than you just as a reminder
of you know damn the Doritos that I want
to be I want to I want to conquer this
every day which is why it's in the
background do you conquer it every day
the bag's not open
to that I don't ever no like that bag
that bag is I don't know how many
probably years old at this point it's
probably nasty to eat them but my mouth
is still watering thinking about them
but when you go out to like I don't know
in the airport and you see Doritos you
don't just pick up a bag ever
um not that's not that I won't pick up a
bag it's like it's intentional so it's
not it's not like I can go to a a office
party or uh event or whatever especially
when you're traveling that's that's the
hardest when you're like everything is
crazy you're not sleeping and you're
speaking at different events and it's
easy as to like the food they have out
is usually crap and just sugar laced
right so I can I can be a lot more
intentional because I've worked the
muscle of seeing that every day so I've
said no every day it's easy to say no
you know when I'm on on a trip it's like
the
thing right you fail so often
often easier to fail right same thing
you work that muscle you become
desensitized or immune to what that is
how about leaning into things that make
you
awkward or feel uncomfortable oh my God
yeah I helped a guy with his YouTube
channel right successful entrepreneur
and he said what's your address I want
to send you I want to send you some art
okay great and so he sent me this and
like this made me so awkward and
uncomfortable that somebody put my face
as the king
like you photoshopped my head hilarious
King's body and I just wanted to hide
this and like put it flat down or throw
it away or something but but okay
because it makes me
awkward
I have to have it in the office
somewhere to see
am I a masochist am I just do I just
love pain or is it an actual good story
if it makes you awkward and you look at
it what I would actually say to that is
what I thought you'd meant is I say what
I believe and I always do with myself I
put myself in uncomfortable situations a
lot like I go where I don't belong a lot
places where like to kind of build to
kind of like to to kind of work that
discomfort a little bit out but I don't
know if I would ever just have a picture
like that around me at every moment
that's hysterical well it was a gift so
I guess it wasn't my my thing but like
for example someone's writing a book
right you've got yours and and we'll
link up the description on the video
here everybody uh if the goal is I want
to be a New York Times best-selling
author like do you then
print out the New York Times
best-selling plaque for yourself I see
what you're saying because it makes you
feel uncomfortable that to me sounds
more like a like a vision board or like
a visualization or manifestation where
you're saying like if I want to have X
I'm gonna put a picture of it I'm going
to visualize it I'm going to do a vision
board is that kind of what you're saying
kind of but like I don't want to be a
king you don't are you sure I don't know
maybe deep down I do you know I gotta
try I gotta I gotta trace my lineage
somewhere and see where you know I might
be the next king of England secretly but
although I
sorry but I think what the thing that
you have in that there I thought the guy
was kind of more indicating that you're
the king of whatever you do oh not that
you're the king of like England but like
okay you know like people say like you
know you're queen queen like you know
what I mean like if you're good at
something it's kind of more of a slaying
or like kind of like a representation
like you're the best you're the goat
um you know well I'm glad he gave me a
King instead of my face on a goat that
that yeah
vision board sure but it's it's
something that you're afraid of
something that makes your heart beat
something that you don't think you're
capable of something that makes you feel
awkward even by looking at that thing
like it's that's yeah 100 but I that's
the way I I the way I kind of explain
that or say is like anything that you
are uncomfortable with that's when you
should do it the most that's why I say
like if you don't want to do it you do
it anyway like one of my big tag lines
is do it anyway because it's when you
are the most uh just when you're most
uncomfortable most most fearful most
scared you know that's when you really
should jump in you know what you know I
did this Ted Talk a few years back like
two and a half years ago uh and it was a
very interesting thing because uh
typically what happens when you do a
talk you know say you got to apply for
them right like you've got to apply to
be a speaker you got to tell them all
these things about you blah blah blah
blah blah and it was kind of the reverse
for me the people at Ted actually
contacted me and they're like you know
we heard of you from so and so we would
really love if you did a speaking thing
and quite honestly speaking is the thing
that I'm scared of the most in life I
never wanted to be a speaker I never
liked to be a speaker I actually it's it
it's true what they say I I rather die
than had to have spoken on like a stage
and so I actually turned it down I was
like you know no thank you I'm not
really I'm not really you know thinking
it's a great time for me right now and I
hung up and I was telling my husband
about it that that night or whatever
he's like are you crazy like why would
you turn it down like everybody wants to
do a TED talk like how like and you
don't have like they out they reached
out to you like Jennifer and I was like
you know what like I gotta take my own
advice here you know like I'm here
talking about in my life about being
bold not because of the book to be
honest with you even before the book
this was like something that I would
always speak about I would always tell
people why are they so scary why can
they just ask for something like don't
let themselves get themselves in their
own way because we always tend to we are
Our Own Worst Enemy we put ourselves in
in the way for us to actually succeed so
after that conversation I'm like you
know what that's true even though I'm
scared more scared of this than anything
else this is why I have to do it and I
call the guys back the next day and I
said you know what I want to do this I
would I would like to do this talk but I
don't want to talk about the things that
you asked me to talk about they wanted
me to talk about health and like how to
like for optimized Health working out
and all these things I'm like what I
want to talk about really is the art of
being bold because without that you
can't get anything in life you can't do
anything if you're not willing to put
yourself out there and what that takes
boldness so if I could talk about that I
will do it and they're like all right do
it and I was so scared Evan I I did it
and I will tell you in the first two
minutes they had to Res they had to stop
The Talk The Ted Talk and you know like
I was so harsh I had zero saliva in my
mouth you know I asked like I was
literally having a panic attack on stage
I had I couldn't even like muster the
words to speak because I had no saliva
they had to stop the talk they had to
like get me a glass of water I had to
drink the glass of water and still I was
like I had notes all over my arm I was a
total disaster and a total mess and
um you know I left the stage I was like
oh my God what a disaster that was awful
but I was so proud of myself that I
actually did it because I was so scared
and guess what happened that that talk
went Ultra viral I mean millions and
millions and millions of people watched
it I think the fact that I was also
relatable because I wasn't perfect right
I didn't know what I was doing I was
clearly an amateur but the message was
really I think really resonated with a
lot of people and uh even though it
wasn't perfect I did it anyway and I put
that fear to the side and thought to
myself this is part of what your message
Jennifer is that when you're scared and
when you don't want to do something you
do it anyway it doesn't have to be
perfect it doesn't have to be you know
amazing it doesn't have to be pristine
but you just have to do it
just to do it and you can learn from it
and like I said it went viral and it was
because of that Ted Talk that I was able
to get my book deal right that was
actually the how I even was able to get
the book deal and from that the funny
thing is a massive part of my business
now is speaking engagements because I
get contacted constantly from all these
companies and people who want me to
speak to their sales teams and to the
schools and high schools and colleges
about basically asking for what you want
and that's another example of how
something that you thought you know you
that was going to be nothing was a was
ended up being a huge opportunity it
opened up all of these doors that I
otherwise would never have got if I said
no and stopped it at that point two of
my favorite tools in the book are 10
Target which we talked about and then
the three F's which we haven't touched
on yet so what are the three F's and how
can we use them to increase our boldness
yes
okay
the three F's are fixed
fix it Farm it out
and the three F's are are the purpose of
them is to give people a framework so
they don't sit and and Waffle too long
and they could put things in
compartments and then move on from them
or or make a decision from them so uh
fix it is if you know if you're if
you're unable to do something you're
going to choose you're gonna choose
either one of these three apps which is
if there is something either you're
going to fix it you know by whatever
whatever means are you gonna forget
about it so it doesn't take up that
brain space or you can Farm it out and
like delegate it to someone else and
those to me are have been very very
instrumental in me moving on and
building out you know pillars of my
career and my personal life to be honest
I talk about that in my book right like
there's certain things I hate about my
if you if you really have a weakness or
something you really don't like about
yourself if you can compartmentalize it
and those things the the amount of like
uh brain power it like gives back to you
is you know is just mountable it's
Bountiful I should say well I love it
because it gives a framework for if
you're stuck what do you do you well
that's stuck because we get stuck on
these things right we get stuck on
things that we don't think we're good at
and we what what we think as people hold
us back you know and if that's what hap
that's it all goes together we get stuck
and then we get into this analysis
paralysis but if you can framework it
into these three F's these for the fix
it varmint and or forget it just like I
said it just saves you so much brain
power and it lets it lets you move to to
the next thing Jennifer last question
you've done so much to help people
you've given so much over the years to
the the speeches and the videos and the
books and everything else if people were
to think of you tonight uh and hold you
in their prayers tonight what would you
have them pray for
oh wow
um I would have them pray for health my
health actually if I want to be if you
want to be honest because without Health
you have nothing and so to me what
that's the first part and for a life of
of richness being fulfillment uh and
Rich relationships uh fulfilling
experiences and opportunities and like
the health of me and my family that's
what I would say
I love what would you say
oh wow nobody's flipped it on me
um
I was all ready to end the show Jed and
cut
um
I'm being bold I yeah I like this she's
she's modeling it um more boldness to be
honest like the boldness to go down and
Chase your mission
yeah
good way to end the episode with that
message the woman is Jennifer Cohen the
book is bigger better Bolder we've
linked it up in the description below go
check it out Jennifer appreciate you as
always thank you so much Alvin to see my
one-on-one with Marie forleo check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there most of us exist in
this space of endless comparison the
compare and despair right so we have
either these idealized versions of
ourselves that we're constantly
comparing ourselves to